bilder aktuell zu sehen im fotomuseum
winterthur keine modefotografin setzt
ihre models erotisch wie humorvoll in
szene wie sie
die bilder der holländerin vivien sassen
sind in den letzten jahren in allen
großen modemagazinen erschienen und
bestechen durch ihren witz
fotoshooting in paris
ww assen fotografiert die neueste
kollektion des modelabels karben
sie ist in der welt der mode zu hause
und doch entspricht sie nicht im
hochglanz klischee der modeindustrie
sie liebt es dinge zu kombinieren die
nicht zusammenpassen und collagiert ihre
bilder auch mal von hand ein hübsches
gesicht allein reicht nicht
wenn es nur ein hübsches mädchen und ein
hübsches kleid ist dann verliere ich
schnell das interesse für mich ist der
körper ein werkzeug
es ist der leben das material das ich in
eine interessante form bringen kann
schon früher hat sich wie wir an sassen
mit der eigenen bildsprache einen namen
gemacht
im fotomuseum winterthur zeigt sie die
letzten 20 jahre ihre bilderwelt die
erotische seite des körpers hat sie
schon immer mehr interessiert als die
kleider die ihn verhüllen
das interesse für die erotik entstand
als ich jung war und damit beschäftigt
meinen eigenen körper und meine eigene
sexualität zu erforschen
das machte spaß das zu ergründen und
sich gleichzeitig über das erotische
lustig zu machen
das stimmt allerdings call
erotik heißt auch nicht alles zu zeigen
das explizite hinter dem banalen
verschwinden zu lassen
global langen beinen ist wie wir uns
hassen nicht zu bremsen ich bin keine
bein vergisst in oder so beine sind
einfach dinge mit denen ich arbeite
sie haben einen eigenen ausdruck und
wenn man sie so hinstellt ist es völlig
anders als so es kann sehr feminin
wirken oder sehr grob es steckt
definitiv in ausdruck in den gliedern
und wie man sie positioniert
die mode fotografie ist immer eine
gratwanderung zwischen origineller
bild.de und den kommerziellen interessen
des geschäfts in einem ihrer
bekanntesten bilder schafft sie es
sowohl model wie auch kleid verschwinden
zu lassen
die idee war dass aus der model eine
blume wird
ich ließ das mädchen auf und ab hüpfen
was ziemlich anstrengend war einen
halben tag hüpfen im feld lassen holt
sich ihre inspiration oft auch in afrika
wo sie ein teil ihrer kindheit verbracht
hat in ghana arbeit sie mit freunden und
bekannten zusammen so wie hier mit zwei
teenager deren haare zusammen geflochten
sind
ohne druck der modeindustrie hat sie
noch mehr freiheit